[Music]
your ex the actor Michael Sheen terrific
actor yes you he is the father of your
daughter as far as we know yes and
confusing I can't remember my wife I
don't know but you're apparently your
daughter as we know is now 17 likes to
occasionally go on the internet and
Google Michael Sheen naked so you've
made that sound creepy and I remember
when he was on here and he said that
yeah he totally made it sound creepy
it's creepy for a daughter to say like
I'm gonna Google pictures of my father
naked my daughter and I both from the
school where we think a naked man is
very funny in the right circumstances
it's not as if something surprise
jumping out at you in a dark alley but
just you know it's a funny thing it's
funny
I dropped my whole life I've been told
that when I'm naked it's very funny I'm
sure apparently there's everyone's
laughing everyone enjoys it except me
I'm just curious
she goes on the internet she Google and
very often it what she's there is a
funny picture of him in a in a very good
show that he did in which he was
brilliant but they have a still of him
sort of getting out of a bathtub naked
with a sort of quite military face and
stance which is just funny and so
sometimes in a low moment she'll text me
that picture or I'll text it to her
I think we have that photo in this sort
of mass cheers everybody out we have
sold everything out we made sure that it
was all pixeled and taken care of
yes so your daughter's feeling low she
sends that she says if I sense that
she's feeling low I think you know what
she she could use Mike in the bath
you know
[Laughter]
you